jack willink how do you deal with
fatigue
both mental and physical
how do i deal with fatigue mental and
physical i rest
and uh you know when when
if i'm feeling like just completely over
trained and weak uh i usually tell
well i tell my fighters i'd say hey you
just got your
butt kicked today go
eat a big steak tonight take tomorrow
off you know you just need rest
and it's pretty obvious when that
happens and so i do the same thing for
myself if i
if i'm feeling horrible and you know you
can see occasionally my workouts
consist of like you know doing some
mobility training rolling it out
you know doing a big stretch that's
because i'm just tired
and i know it and so i just give myself
some down time
i think it's very important to know the
difference
between being lazy and being over
trained
and it's very easy to make that excuse
for yourself and that's why i
always err on the side of i'm working
out i'm training
because and usually then the next day
so if i feel like exhausted today
i won't take today off but i will take
the next day but i'll work out today
just to make sure
right that i'm not just being lazy so
i'll do another workout get another
training session in or whatever the case
may be
so i make sure that's not just that
moment because sometimes the next day
you're like you know i'm not that bad
right i'm gonna get i'm back in the game
yeah back on the program
the uh the other thing people ask me all
the time
i've probably written this a dozen times
or more on twitter
is do i take naps and the answer is yes
in fact i slept on the i flew today and
i slept
probably two hours on the plane um and
that's a little bit more than a nap and
i'm not on a plane every day so what do
i do for naps yes i do take naps
what i do for naps and this is something
that i learned from a high school
teacher that i had
was i walked into his office one day and
he had his feet up on the desk
above his heart and i said you know what
are you doing
and he said oh this is really good for
you you put your feet above your heart
and it allows the blood to circulate out
of your feet and gives you know lets
your
your veins and your one-way valves and
your veins rest a little bit
and gets little pools of blood out of
random places and it's
getting good and so i tried it and it
felt really good
and so when i was going through seal
training i used to when i come in we'd
we'd have like a couple minutes in
between evolutions and i just go in and
put my feet upside my alarm clock
sleep for a few minutes you know
nowadays if i can i'll try and sleep for
like
six to eight minutes set my timer on my
iphone
and you look like distressed when i said
six to eight minutes
yeah you don't consider anything under
the three hours
yeah that's not a legitimate nap not a
legitimate nap if i sleep for
like an hour then i'm up for too long at
night i won't be able to go to sleep
with too much rest gotcha yeah
under what circumstances are you going
to take a nap though like how do you how
do you just
feel i'm just tired i'll feel myself
like now oh yes like sleepy tired and
that's the thing is
i can do if i'm if my mind is engaged in
something or especially if my body's
engaged in something that's what's cool
about working out you can work out when
you're exhausted
because once you start moving it's not
like you're gonna fall asleep while
you're doing squats right it's like
you're gonna fall asleep while you're
doing pull-ups
yeah you're just gonna do the pull-ups
you're just gonna do the squats and when
you get done you'll be tired you're
going to sleep
right what's hard to do and this is when
like when we were writing the book
when i was writing my section of books
i'd be writing at night 11 o'clock at
night 12 o'clock at night
be trying to hammer through it and
sometimes i just fall you know i'd be
falling asleep
oh man so but that feeling of hey i'm
just falling asleep
right that's not good i know so when i'm
feeling that tired i'll all power not
but it's like one of those things where
i also like to push through it so
someone was just trying to power through
it because honestly even even a short
nap for me
will kind of make me stay up too late at
night and all of a sudden it'll be one
o'clock in the morning
six to eight minutes six to eight
minutes six eight minutes a power nap a
six to eight minute power nap can make
you feel amazing oh yeah
it can make you feel amazing don't
underestimate the power nap it is a
legit
fool right there yeah i i actually used
to take like 15
minute nah like yeah 15 minutes yeah i
know that's overkill for you that's
a little much going into laziness but
seriously 15 minutes is yeah you
probably felt like
yeah outstanding but it only helps with
that sleepy time because
let's say i'm used to a certain amount
of sleep let's say i get two and a half
hours less sleep than i'm used to
it goes way beyond me feeling just
sleepy tired it's like
physically tired oh really yeah so yeah
i don't have that issue
yeah yes you're different
so if i take a 10 minute power nap
when i am lacking two and a half hours
of my quote-unquote oh it'll make up for
it right
no no no no no no it helps me when i get
my normal sleep give or take
but i've been doing a lot of stuff
during the day
you know and you're like dang i did a
lot my brain was
kind of used a lot and dang i have this
whatever i got to do now
yeah then you take the 10 15 minute nap
then it it brings you right back yeah
and it typically will not mess with my
sleeve i wonder how much of this is just
you just not just powering through stuff
yeah probably all of it but nonetheless
that's how it is
yeah for me for sure it'd be interesting
to
at some point for you to experiment with
like lack of sleep and sleep deprivation
and see
how well you can perform like i've been
noticing that where
if i don't get a lot of sleep i can
still perform really well yeah
at some physical activities and then
after a few days though i do i could
feel like garbage right and there'll be
some physical activities that i'll field
a week at
but yeah and and you're right
well there the i mean as long as it's
like one time or even two times or
so if i film or something and like let's
say i film in the morning but then i've
been up
you know working late the night before
when i go into film i'm like
charged up i'm sure there's all kinds of
factors in there a lot of it's like
like adrenaline not like it's like this
huge adrenaline rush but there's that
little bit of adrenaline because of the
task you know
so that helps and um a lot of times just
like how you said
if i made the decision like no i'm not
gonna miss this workout
at all under any circumstances then i
happen to get two and a half hours less
sleep then
and i go in and how you say power
through it
you can you can totally do it yeah but
i'm seeking comfort
fully yeah for sure but it still doesn't
help though but to answer the question
yes if you're tired sleep if you need
rest
rest and don't try and over
train yourself you probably are over
training and
and just need some rest yeah